[Music]
my challenge for this assignment was to
essentially try and photograph something
that had happened that wasn't ongoing
and to use the landscape locations
internet cafes places that had seen an
involvement in a huge world issue that
arguably might have changed the outcome
of the u.s. election there used to be a
factory over on the horizon there used
to be this here there used to be that
here when I began to think about you
know those jobs and the opportunities
the jobs that were lost or the
opportunities that were now available to
Macedonians in that town particularly
tavella's is youth then that gave me an
idea that well if there were a feeling
of no opportunities or the young
people's options were severely limited
then I could begin to work from that and
that perhaps this story rather than
having people in the midst of doing
things I could rely on the recent
history in the location to piece this
story together like that they figured
very early on that the stories just
through analytics and data the stories
that were clicked most the stories that
were followed through on Facebook to
their logical conclusion were the
outrageous stories of Trump supporters
and the Republican Party and they very
quickly realized that there was much
more money to be made but in very small
increments half a cent whatever it is
through Google ad revenue that you get
that the people that clicked on links
the most who didn't check their veracity
who didn't care for it who just wanted
to see the headline were Trump
supporters
and so with Boris you know the guy just
wanted to make some money and when he
was making lots of money he managed he
figured he quit school I don't think his
teachers were particularly you know
strong trying to get into germane in
school he was making a lot of money more
money than they would in a year they
encouraged him it was always my
intention to capture a more reporters
moment of him engaging with with his
friends perhaps in one of those internet
cafes perhaps in one of those bars but
all of those things just didn't
materialize in the way that I would have
liked to I spoke to him about how he
would like to be photographed how he
would like to be sitting where we should
do it it was a cooperation to get that
picture with him sitting on the computer
screen Macedonia's response to being
caught up or being the center of one of
the biggest stories of 2016 with fake
news and the sharing of fake news online
I think was met with kind of a little
bit of grudging respect for the people
that had done it there was something
else out there and they wanted a piece
of it